abone ol
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Ama
bende sizler gibi şehirde yaşıyordum bir
zamanlar büyükşehirde beyaz yakalı hırsı
inanılmaz kariyer hedefleri olan bir
model dim başarılıydım da fakat
Anneannem benim için Kutlu der babam
rahat sivri bir şeydir bunu hep batar
der Ve nitekim öyle oldu 40'a varmadan
yaşadığımız toplum bilinçsizliği miz şu
uğursuzluğu muz
Taksim'de kesilen iki tane ağaç akabinde
yaşananlar maden patlamaları garlarda
patlayan bombalar
derken ben çuko şehirlerde yaşamak
istemedim şunu düşündüm emeklilik
gelecekti Ben özgürleşecek Team doğaya
dönecektim ama yarın sabah uyanıp
uyuyamayacağım bilmiyordum öyle bir
enteresan lık var Bir gün kötü bir gün
işten döndü mi bu trafiği Kaos
delirdim ve internete kiralık köy evi
yazdım İngiltere'de okurken arıcılık
eğitimi almıştım
kazdağları'nda 79 tane endemik bitki
yetişiyor bunlardan 32 tanesi Dünyada
sadece Kaz Dağları'nda yetişiyor
emeklilik zamanı arıcılık yapacağını
biliyordum Dolayısıyla Kazdağları o Evo
ilan doğru ilanı ve ben ertesi gün
kapora gönderdim
şimi ki hafta içerisinde taşındım her
şeyi bıraktım çektim gittim İyi de ettim
sonrasında İlk zamanlar akademisyenliğe
uzaktan sürdürmeye çalıştım ayda bir şey
İstanbul'a geldim Seminerler verdim
Yetmedi bir süre sonra çevirmenlik
yapmaya başladım isteğim arıcılık the
ama konuyu oğlaklarla girdim oğlaklar
Meğer insan bebekleri gibi Ağlarmış Ben
bir kaç gece üst üste bir bebek ağlıyor
kimse susturuyor bu derken bir komşunun
kapısında Bittim bu bebeğe bakacak kimse
yoksa ben bakarım Ağlamasın Dedim
dediler ki onlar oğlak O oğlaklar bir
süre sonra birkaç hafta sonra gözümün
önünde zıplamaya başladılar inanılmaz
şekerler her bir çok tatlı sonra o
oğlaklar iki ay geçmeden sıra sıra kesme
alınmaya başladılar Yani komşum
tarafından İnsanlar pek seviyormuş içini
Nike silmesinler diye oğlakları aldım
Şimdi keçiler yoktu süt ürünleri yoktu
ama süt ürünleri ve keçiler Böylece
başladı arılardan önce başladı
sonrasında birkaç kovan edindim
Havran'da yaptırdım aldım araları da
hayatımı dahil ettim bir parçacık üretim
yaptım o güne kadar hiç sosyal medyada
yoktum Facebook sayfam yoktu hiçbir şey
yoktu Ben muhabbetten çok
stabil bir hayatı olan
kesikli beyaz yakaladım biraz sıkıcı
adam hak o neydi ürünler o meydana
çıktıktan sonra bir etiket gerekli bir
isim gerekti bir gün ormanda yürürken bu
arada sizlere ürün sunacağım marka
arıyorum yani ismi ne olacak Ne olacak
diye düşünürken Leylacığım önce
koşturuyor püskülle beraber dedim ki
Leyla'nın ismini vereyim Leyla hep ben
zannediyorsunuz ama Leyla fotoğraftaki
kutup ayısı Leyla'nın ismi vermeye karar
verdim ama ne olacaktı Leyla'nın devamı
işte Gurme şok Olmaz Benden yani o
organik kelimesini biraz sinir oluyorum
açıkçası kullanmak istemedim ben anne
tarafından sadece baba tarafından sonucu
bir aileden geliyorum ve İngiltere'de
okurken en çok Mehmet bakkalın beyaz
peyniri AŞ eriyordum ve annemden sürekli
onu istiyorum dedim ki hazır unutuluyor
zaten unutuldu neredeyse
Bakkal defteri de çok kıymetli bir
şeydir O da unutuldu neredeyse Ben dedim
Bakkal olayım neo-liberal in karşısına
Bakkal olarak çıkmakta ve hoş geldi O da
güzel bir refleks Oh oturdu derken Leyla
Bakkal kuruldu Leyla bakın ardından
bugün bakıyorum Yıllar yıllar önce artık
ellerinde kocaman sermayeleri olan ve
sizlere
başka başka markalarla ürünler sunan
markaların hemen hepsinin bir alt
markası var ve ismi bir şey Bakkal
aranızdan kopup köy hayatına dağlara
yerleşen üretim yapmaya başlayanlar bir
marka kurarlarsa bakıyorum isimlerin
yanında bakkal var hatta bu pandemi
sürecinde biliyorsunuz ekonomi ayvayı
yedi her ne kadar şu aralar 7'ye kadar
yemiş olsa da bir devlet bankası
sanıyorum Halkbank Bakkal kredisi diye
bir kredi açtı Dolayısıyla bu öpeceğim
iz memlekete yeniden bakkalı kazandırdı
Ben de Bakkal defteri kültürünü ilk
günden beri yaşatmak istedim Hala bu
konuda dirençli yim şöyle yapıyorum ürün
gönderiyorum ödeme almıyorum ürünler siz
bu çıktıktan sonra müsait vaktiniz de
parasını ödüyorsunuz Ben varlıklı
denilebilecek insanların yaşadığı bir
çevrede büyüdüm varlıklı lık bir acayip
bir şey bir vardır bir yoktur kimi zaman
yok olduğunu Bakkal defteri bilir
Bakkal bilir ama Konu komşu pek bilinmez
kuyruğu dik tutarsın Ben de o kültürü
hakikaten sürdürelim istedim Altı
senedir sürüyor reflekslerin sonucunda
doğaya gittiğimde doğayı Buldun mu Evet
güzel bir Doğa buldum cennet gibi yerler
ama içerisi Zebani dolu Çünkü çok ciddi
bir cehalet var bu cehaletin akabinde
kendini
gönüllü öğretmenliğe verdim Ben 6
senedir gönüllü öğretmenlik yapıyorum
yaşadığım bölgede ilk dönem kendi evinde
dersler vermeye başladım Sonra
komşularımın evlerine gitmeye başladım
derken ilçede yaşayan başka köylerde
yaşayan öğrenciler için
kahvelerde buluşup sınıfları açtım ev bu
sınıflar açtım derken bugün 53 tane
çocuğum var şu an üniversitede okuyan
hepsinin bursu var bu sene garanti
veriyorum Sudenaz Tıp kazanacak bu
topluma bir doktor daha geliyor Kaan bu
sene Uludağ Üniversitesi Ziraat
fakültesini bitiriyor Bir ziraat
mühendisimiz var ve bir iki saat önce
Almanya'dan benden alışveriş yapan ve bu
şekilde tanıştığın canım Elif'le
konuştuk bir ihtimal de Kaan Almanya bir
organik çiftliğe staj yapmaya gidecek
Sonrasında da memlekete dönecek ve bu
topraklara katkı sağlayacak sizlere
bugün sizin reflekslerin izin pandomin
sonrasında gelişmiş reflekslerin izin
biraz doğaya benim köyüme Bizim oralara
neler ettiğinden bahsetmek istiyorum
anlatmak istiyorum Bunlar biraz Elzem
konular Çünkü pandemi ile birlikte evet
Ölüm girdi hayatımıza Ve
sevdiklerimizden ayrıldık Herkeste bir
doğaya dönme paniği doğaya sahip çıkma
paniği var bunu görüyorum böyle reflexes
oldu bu refleks sonucunda benim köyüm
şantiyeye döndü koca koca
holdingler geldi yüzlerce dönüm araziler
satın alındı bundan iki sene önce
alabileceğiniz bir köy evine bugün 4-5
katı daha fazla paraları alır olduğunuz
inanılmaz bir Sürdürülebilir köy hayatı
diye bir şey gaz lanıyor bu durum
Açıkçası beni üzüyor orada oradayım
içindeyim görüyorum doğaya olana
görüyorum ve ona üzülüyorum sizlere
olanı görüyorum ve ona üzülüyorum çünkü
ben de sizler gibi şehirde yaşadım ömrüm
ipotekli ydi faturaları ipotekli idim
oruçları ipotekli idi arabanın benzinli
köprünün girişine doğalgaza her şey
ipotekli
dibe şimdi Sizler köye dönmek için
ömürlerini bu eklemeye devam ediyorsunuz
bunu görüyorum ve buna çok üzülüyorum
gerçekten çözüm bu olmamalı ben
hayatımın bir döneminde Arnavutköy'de
bir yılı dairesinde de yaşadım
baltalimanı'nda denize sıfır başka bir
yılı dairesinde de yaşadım Bugün tam iki
göz odadan ibaret bir köy evinde
yaşıyorum inanın O evlerin hepsi aynı
yalnızlığı aynı mutsuzluğu ya da
mutluluğu you aynı huzurlu ya da
huzursuzluğu barındırıyor bizlerin köye
dönelim doğaya dönelim ama şehirdeki
konforla dönelim talebimiz Benim Sizlere
ya da arıların sizlere doğal bal Suna
mamasına neden oluyor keçilerin otlaya
mamasına neden oluyor Bir sonraki nesile
su bırakamama ya neden oluyor Bundan
dolayı Açıkçası ben bugün buraya
reflekslerimiz E biraz sahip olalım
aklımızı kullanalım akıllıca adımlar
atalım demeye Ha bu arada besin
zincirinin en tepesindeyiz Bizler Gerçi
bu hani 12 bin yıl önce Tarım devrimi
ile zoka yuttuğumuz andan itibaren böyle
Ondan öncesinde daha doğayla yaşayan
doğanın bir parçası olarak yaşayan
vatandaş değil yaşam Daş olduğumuz
dönemler miş
yeniden bu birinci dönmek gerektiğini
düşünüyorum çünkü bakın akıllı insanın
ya aklımız var ya patronunuz kralız biz
her şeyin sahibiyiz biz akıllı insanın
neler yaptığını size anlatmak istiyorum
mesela akıllı insanın akılsız saydığı
elma ağacının nasıl fizik kimya
matematik bildiğini hemencecik
örneklerini istiyorum size burada bir
elma ağacı bize meyve vermek için çiçeği
durduğunda çok basit bir tahlile önce
köklerini saldı toprağa analiz ediyor
sonra köklerinin gücüne bakıyor
gövdesinin dallarının gücüne bakıyor Biz
bunu kimya diyoruz son Evet Ee o daldaki
çiçeğinin sayısına bakıyor ve o dalda
onca çiçeği meyve döndürülürse taşıyıp
taşıyamayacağı na dair bir hesap yapıyor
biz buna fizik diyoruz
taşıyamayacağı kadarını ağaçtan döküyor
ve taşıyabileceği kadarını Bize gerçek
meyveler olarak sunuyor Şahane inanın
insanın Yaptığı hiçbir işlemde yüzdeyüz
doğruluk Payı yok ama elma ağacının var
Biz Akıl sahibi insanlar şunu yapıyoruz
çiçeğe ağaca çiçek çiçek verdiği anda O
çiçekleri 4 Mason Aman bize her birini
bir elma ağacına çevirsin diye ilaç
uyguluyoruz buz Normalde bir elma ağacı
50 ile 80 seni arasında yaşar böyle bir
zulme dayanamadı için ağaç bizlerle en
çok 10-15 sene kalıyor ve bize her
seferinde bütün bu üzerine meyve
döndürüp meyve olarak verdiği için meyve
de veremiyor sadece elma görüntüsünde
besin değeri olması gerekeni yüzde biri
içeriğinde
heykelcikler veriyor ve biz onları
yiyoruz biz bunu akıllı besin zincirinin
patronu olarak yapıyoruz insan olarak
yapıyoruz bakıyorsun üç beş kişi para
kazanıyor o elma ağacının fidanı satan
kazanıyor o ilacı satan kazanıyor ya da
o elmayı hasat edip sizlere sunan
kazanıyor para kazanıyor ama bir yandan
çok ciddi hastalıklar ve ölüm alıyoruz
karşılığında Bunu bir türlü hesap
edemiyoruz bir türlü
bu hadsizliği nize dur diyemiyoruz
nedendir bilmiyorum ama böyle bir
halimiz var Sonra kendimizi kandırmak
konusunda da mağazamız mesela plastiği
dönüştürüyoruz şu anda böyle bir gaz
varsa Ben bilmem ne deterjanı diyor ki
size dönüştürülmüş plastik ile Geldim
Sana artık daha masum Uu hiç inanın
değil gerçekten değil Build önüş
tükürmüş plastiğe bakalım 1950'den 2017
senesine kadar
ürettiğimiz
milyon ton bakın
9200 milyon ton
plastiğini sadece
600000000 tonunu şey yapabilmiş Siz geri
dönüştürebilirsiniz yüzde onu bile değil
çok çok küçük yüzdelerde geri dönüştüre
biliyoruz imha ediyoruz nasıl imha
ediyoruz yakarak imha ediyoruz Toprağın
altına gömerek imha ediyoruz şöyle bir
örnek vereyim s köyde yaşamaya ilk
başladığımda böyle ormanda yürüyorum
inanılmaz çayırlar bayırlar ve bayır
aşağı böyle [ __ ] gibi çöpler Ben dedim ki
ben şimdi bilinçli okumuş insan olarak
giderdi burayı temizler semt bu örnek
olurum ve sonrasında oraya atılmaz çöp
ilk seferini 80 küsür çuval çöp topladım
Bugün gitsek 800 çuvalla temizle yemeyiz
sonrasında baktım hiçbir şey değişmiyor
insanlara ağabey hıyarın teki geldi
temizledi Hadi biz daha devam edelim
diyorlar ve Hakikaten bu sistem yürüyor
Sonra dedim ki ben atılan molozları
Şikayet Edeyim bari yetkili merciler
İşlerini yapsınlar atılan molozların
şikayet edip işini yapmayan belediye ile
Bilmem nereye şikayet edip onu ona onu
ona bir bilgi bir şekilde birilerini
İşini Yapmaya mecbur bıraktığında ne
oldu biliyor musunuz gelip o
molozların plastiklerin hepsinin üzerine
Toprak döktüler
Biz temizliği de böyle yapıyoruz Nitekim
şemada gösteriyor bunu bakın burada
yazıyor gömüldü yada doğaya bırakıldı
en korkunç ne kadarı yarısından fazlası
Biz bunu yapıyoruz bununla geri
dönüştürüyoruz hayatlarımızda tüketirken
hakikaten artık Çok bilinçli davranmamız
lazım bana soruyorsunuz ya da diğer
üreticilere soruyorsunuz soğanın bağlı
ne kadar doğal o Elma ne kadar doğal
inanın bunun ne kadar doğal olduğu
sizlere bağlı bizlere bağlı çamaşır suyu
kullanmaya devam ediyoruz hala deli gibi
Temizlik imandan gelir böyle Yaradana
sığınıp 40 lıyoruz ortalığı sonra
kirletiyoruz doğayı Çünkü o çamaşır
suyunu Siz denize gönderiyorsunuz
yeraltı Kaynak Sularını göndermiş
oluyorsunuz buharlaşıp Bulut olup
tepemize yağıyor arama için bize ve
nasıl yetişsin nasıl bize doğal ürün
versin
inanılmaz su tüketiyoruz inanılmaz
gerçekten Burada hep birlikte şimdi 1.30
saniye Evet şu anda su yok bitti diyelim
ve bir düşünelim bakalım ne ne olacak
doğaya dönün Evet gelin ne olur gelin
çok isterim yani Sizler oraya
geldiğinizde biliyorum ki oradaki bilinç
seviyesi yükselecek ama ne olursunuz
doğaya Sürdürülebilir köy şeklinde köy
hayatı yaşamaya gelmeyin doğaya
geliyorlar köyde yaşamaya geliyorlar üç
gün sonra kavga çıkıyor Daha bir sene
olmadı Nadir abiyi köye yeni taşınmış
bir şehirlinin elinden aldık adam kavga
ediyor diyor ki
inek bağırıyor diyor ya ineğin sesinden
rahatsız olmuş gelme Baba gelme ya Köye
gelme yani eşek alıyor diyor gelme
istemiyorum yani
projelere bakıyorum köyümde kurulan
projelere bakıyorum o kadar sahtekar
lılar ki Yani o kadar sahtekar Hepsi Bir
kere hepsini içerisinde Köy Enstitüsü
var biliyor musunuz böyle bir kepazelik
olamaz inanılmaz sen bir yerlere
inanılmaz yerler yapıyorlar ve size
verecekleri en çok 500 metrekare için
sizlerden Milyonlar talep ediyorlar Bu
arada ben de yaşadım bu yaz biliyor
musunuz bu kış Ben gönüllü öğretmenliği
gönüllü olarak birazcık ara verdim çok
yoruldum Çünkü çok çok yoruldum
inanılmaz ya O 53 çocuk hakikaten eğitme
kısmında yorulmadım onların çevresiyle
uğraşmaktan yoruldum yaptığım işlerin
Balta lan masasından yoruldum ya da ben
o işleri yapmayayım diye Köpeğimin
başına Kurşun sıkıp Bana da fotoğrafını
atılmasından yoruldum her cümlenin
yalnız kadınsın ayağını denk al diye
başlamasından yoruldum çok yoruldum O
yüzden ara verdim niye biliyor musunuz
Ben bu yaz Bahçemde bostanın ortasında
kocaman bir Ahlat ağacım var onun altına
bir açık hava sınıfı yaptım istedim ki
çocuklar yazın gelsinler ve bende bu
eğitim yükünü birazcık c 12 diğer
akademisyen arkadaşlarımla paylaşayım Ve
nitekim oldu da o benim güzelim
akademisyen arkadaşlarım İstanbul'un en
en
iyi üniversitelerinden üç ayrı
Üniversitesi'nden Profesör ve doçentler
deliler gibi gelir o bahçede çadır
kurarız Biz yaşarız bahçende ders de
veririz bilgisayarlar topladık çocuklara
robotik uygulama atölyesi çocuklara
bilgisayar kodlama dersi verecektik Ne
yaptılar biliyor musunuz bostanım a
giren üç yolu birden kapattılar Tabii ki
yetkili mercilere ulaşana kadar çok
çabaladım Çanakkale valisi İlhan Bey
buradan çok çok teşekkür ediyorum
bize bir bahçe mi ulaşacak bir yol yaptı
Fakat o yol yapılana kadar da Benim
akademisinin arkadaşlarımın artık
şehirlere dönüp mesailerine başlaması
gerekir O Pro Ne kaldı şey değil Çok
Dert değil hani Mart ayında
ilçedeki hem Anadolu Lisesi'nde hemen
fen lisesinde Online olarak başlayacağız
ve yazın yeniden Ben bir gayret o sınıfı
ayaklandırma ya çalışacağım ama bunların
hiçbirisi kolaylıkla olmuyor Bunların
hepsi eğitimle bilinçli oluyor Bundan
dolayı çok istiyorum Sizler köylere
gelin Evet gelin Banada destek olun
Sizler de benzer şeyler yapın Çünkü
artık test Sistem çöktü görüyorsunuz
Şahane artık tür ettiğimiz ürettiğimiz
bir sistemin içerisindeyiz artık dayanış
arak yaşamayı öğrenmemiz gereken bir
dönemdeyiz çok teşekkür ediyorum
dinlediğin için